fue anunciada el domingo pasado
provocando estupor entre los israelíes
un país entero obligado a reactivar el
aislamiento para frenar la epidemia
el método es cuestionado por cientos de
manifestantes reunidos entre la vid
entre ellos científicos y médicos
el confinamiento es ineficaz e incluso
desastroso hace más daño que cualquier
otra cosa no va a detener la pandemia
cierre de escuelas restaurantes salas de
deportes y todas las tiendas no
esenciales durante tres semanas a los
israelíes también se les prohíbe moverse
a más de 500 metros de sus casas y
reunirse en grupos de más de diez
personas en interiores 20 al aire libre
un arsenal de medidas en un momento en
el que el país se enfrenta a un
preocupante resurgimiento del virus la
tasa de contagio en israel es ahora una
de las más altas del mundo y hay cientos
de pacientes en los servicios de
emergencia muchos de ellos en estado
grave según el primer ministro benjamin
netanyahu hay que evitar la saturación
del sistema de salud
en los últimos dos días hemos visto un
nuevo aumento alarmante la mortalidad y
un aumento constante del número de
pacientes en condiciones críticas la
situación y las recomendaciones de
muchos especialistas no nos dejan otra
opción que reforzar las medidas
entre confinamiento que según la
oposición israelí podría tener efectos
devastadores en la economía ya golpeada
por la primera ola
las nuevas medidas entraron en vigor en
la víspera del año nuevo judío un tiempo
de celebraciones tanto religiosas como
familiares